what's up guys it's christmas today
merry merry christmas
and here at the chan house we just
finished opening our presents
and uh have one more present and i
wanted to record a reaction video
of my parents and it's not it's not a
physical gift because off-camera you're
saying this is not a uh
what was the word you're thinking of i
still think it's remember i still can't
think of material material yeah i don't
know
not a tangible tangible yes that's what
i was thinking about
non-tangible yes all right so you know
me and tiff we have a vlog channel right
but
you also uh had a hobby when me and
carrie were born
you recorded a lot of videos of course
yeah we did
yes and so i was wondering if you were a
vlogger too what would those vlogs look
like
and so i decided to just kind of put my
own editing onto
some of those videos okay so i want to
just uh share a little bit of our memory
lane with you who's the pioneer
yeah you're the pioneer all right and
hit it
baby casey baby casey
who did that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you think you're cute yeah it's a baby
all babies are cute how are you gonna
say a baby's not cute
yeah yeah this is like the very first
first footage you recorded
it
[Music]
yeah it took me a while to get all the
subtitles down
[Music]
casey
casey hey do you have all the videos
just portioned i only edited a portrait
there's so much video i only edited like
like a fraction of all the footage i had
[Laughter]
they're already big
you're also very allergic to 1988 so you
were just six months old yeah it's
christmas too
this is exactly 32 years ago
[Music]
[Music]
you just woke up
[Music]
can you remember
[Music]
nothing happened nothing to see
[Music]
they here some music to it huh yeah i
edited it as if
it was my vlog
[Music]
footage vlog yeah pretty much
[Music]
yeah and i was like what was the cool
music at that time oh look at my car
i don't miss the car
i'm just a spider
that's a cool car yeah
[Music]
yeah i missed that trooper too actually
i wish i still had it
[Music]
look at that camera how big it is
[Music]
30 years ago no more than that right 32
years ago
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is a new camera the first time we
did it
while you're driving you know that's
such a rare
what you say you're gonna end up
recording me uh
uh crashing the car oh then what i said
yeah
right after christmas
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're like six months old right yeah
six months
okay
[Music]
do you remember this day i remember i
actually remember the
[Music]
[Music]
oh
okay
okay
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
my yeah i can't do that anymore
you should try oh no
oh no it won't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah this is before you knew i was
allergic yeah he was like breaking up
you know that's a bad doctor
[Music]
i look so 80s
[Laughter]
i think i'm so 80.
i'm trying to flex my eyebrows you still
do that to this day
you make some of those faces
[Music]
happy new year
[Laughter]
oh i think the head dropped too and come
up 1989.
89. i figure i was born yeah oh you were
awesome
my mom was about to get pregnant next
[Laughter]
month
[Music]
sound like the thing that she was
blowing into
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he thought he was being swallowed
i was like if you guys had a vlog
[Applause]
[Music]
do you remember that day oh yeah
absolutely i remember singaporean
wow i remember that in the video
you know you know you know i don't know
it's a video or really that day but
was your memory here you remember i
don't remember anything
you're already vlogging way before
actually how many years before youtube
youtube came out what
2005. and we're
but we were not like now you know you
guys talking to
it and explaining but you guys had
enough conversation to actually
make something out of it though that
when i was editing i was thinking like
oh it might be a lot of just montage
like just music and no talking but
you guys are actually having enough
candid conversations to
actually interesting make it interesting
yeah and let's call that
i like how you're talking about the
mailman and about how like the mail was
on
that's like a day-in-the-life thing
i think uh you get a lot of conversation
when there's a baby
true
yeah yeah teaching the baby you're
talking to the baby entertaining the
baby
true the first video that with a lot of
dialogue is that when she was
walking around the house at house and
did a house tour oh you saw that i have
that you have that that's the next one
it was lovely it was a good memory
i remember every moment of it yeah yeah
like it was yesterday
do you remember the way it smelled in
the car or yesterday or something
yeah it was nice
[Music]
foreign